mr putin must stop this madness
and he must stop it now an emergency
meeting of the u.n security council
brought international condemnation of
russia's shelling and seizure of
europe's largest nuclear power plant
this is the first time that a state has
attacked
a fueled and functioning nuclear power
plant
moscow delivered only more defiance
another attempt by the kiev authorities
to kindle artificial hysteria about what
is taking place in ukraine there's
little sense vladimir putin sees reason
to change course now
after nato foreign ministers agreed they
will not grant ukraine's wish to
establish a no-fly zone even as the
alliance predicts more bloodshed the
days to come
are likely to be worse
with more death
more suffering
and more destruction
the west seems to believe putin may find
his invasion unsustainable sanctions
have pushed russia's economy to the
brink of collapse russia's army has
suffered heavy losses and the kremlin is
now censoring news of the war at home
president putin
totally underestimated the strength of
the ukrainian armed forces
and they have been able to push back to
fight bank and to slow down the russian
advances and in defiance of putin's
demands ukraine is quickly moving closer
to europe the eu said it wants ukraine
to become a member as soon as possible
while allies canada and the united
kingdom were invited to join a meeting
of european foreign ministers to shore
up support our goal is to make sure that
we put maximum pressure on russia yet
ukraine believes it's not enough to
deter putin's grand ambitions warning
nato may still have to take up the fight
it is so desperate to avoid since the
start of the invasion there's been no
formal contact between the american
military and the russian military
fearing this could spiral into direct
conflict the two sides have now
established a deconfliction hotline
donna the pentagon says it works they
say they placed a test call and the
russians answered
interesting jackson frosco in washington
thanks